what a good evening so many of you have
been my students in classes and you have
been exposed to surprising concepts and
some of you have not so this time this
is the last lecture so that I'm going to
leave with you hopefully good dosage of
supply chain principles and for those of
you who have taken my classes this there
was somewhat of a review but also is
looking at it in a more structured way
yeah so hopefully everybody would
benefit from this last lecture yes the
title that I want to share with you is
the triple a supply chain I think some
of you may know that I have written an
article in the late to serve 200 for
which has exactly the same title on the
triple a supply chain in the Harvard
Business Review I wanted to use that
same framework but hopefully given more
of the current thinking about the
subject and some of the latest examples
and perspective on how companies as in
companies enterprises in both product
companies or service companies or any
organizations need to have these three a
kind of characteristics I think this is
applicable whether you're talking about
producing a car on computer or whether
you are serving in need of some some
type of services the Triple A concepts I
think hopefully would be useful yes so
why triple a triple a is necessary
mainly because I think it's also an
exciting title when you talk about
single a that's not exciting single a
these days especially Coco Xie GSP
doesn't use ABC as Grey's but in other
parts of campuses that we do use a and B
and C and these days with great
inflation having an A is nothing to be
proud of yeah you need multiple age yeah
so that's why triple-a triple-a bonds is
usually considered to be a sign of
excellence and I do believe that
companies that want to be excellent in
supplying type of companies or service
companies need to possess three what I
call properties and these three
properties all start with the letter A
and that's why I call them Triple A
supply chain interestingly is that I
think those companies that have these
three properties would also have Triple
A type of
performance in terms of excellence okay
so just to prepare you I wanted to show
you maybe some recent studies studies in
203 that was jointly conducted by
Stanford University and in Seattle with
also participation from Accenture which
of course that's important the study was
looking at whether companies who are
considered to be excellent in supply
chain performance and by supply chains
are usually what I meant is like
inventory turn speed cycle time pause
that kind of performance related to how
well you support your operations and
whether those would be related to
financial ultimate market performance so
this is the two things that we want to
know is that if you work hard and
getting cycle time down and even return
good and so on would you be rewarded is
it related actually in the perfect
performance in the market and so the
simple relationship that we look at is
if a company has improved in your supply
chain performances or decline or
maintain the same level what happened to
their market cap and there are four
kinds of companies in this diagram here
versus mic or supply chain leaders these
are companies that have always performed
well with the beginning of the 90s in
the second part of the 90s companies
that are core transformers are those
that did not perform well that they
later on they have improved leg are the
ones that have always performed below
industry average and the decliners used
to be performed well in the beginning of
the 90s but there they have declined and
sure enough there is a correlation the
correlation is that indeed those
companies that seem to perform well in a
supply chain have also enjoyed higher
than industry average in market caps and
of course the decliners have been
heavily penalized by the market because
of the performance so there is no clear
cause sanity relationship but definitely
there is a correlation similarly a some
colleagues of mine at Georgia Tech has
done some study looking at the soak or
supply chain glitches by glitches what
they meant is that there were some
reported reported problems that these
companies have either because of
shortages or because of something is not
enough
Vasiliy running down and they found that
those glitches often times resulted in
significant underperformance compared to
a comparable company in the same sector
so they pair them up and found that even
before or after those incidents there
are significant significant
underperformance as a result of these
creatures so all this means is that
companies do need to is important for
them to have good design good marketing
everything puts set up leadership but
you also have to have a good engine to
deliver products to deliver orders to
satisfy your customers so today why was
it the case that it's so difficult for
companies to manage your supply chain
well now I think of course this is
self-serving I think there are three
major trends that make things difficult
yes and there are three three is an easy
number to remember yeah so three things
so the first one is that is increasing
uncertainty the market is very uncertain
in the world is easy if everything is
predictable the second one is that
things are changing rapidly product life
cycles are shorter and shorter and so
yes you may found a good solution for
this product but the next product has
just come out you are at the end of life
cycle as soon as you introduce a new
product then when I cycles are three
months long four months long that's the
kind of rapid changes that we're talking
about the technology will also changing
rapidly and third very few companies can
do it all that you have to depend on
many partners to produce a product or
make a surface and so there many many
players that you have to depend on and
those play players have their own
self-interest too and they may not see
eye-to-eye with you and you have to make
sure that their interest somehow
hopefully is aligned with yours so
because of these three challengers
that's why I think we need three
properties and those three poverty's
remember yeah there is attached at the
end of this last lecture series there's
a last example yeah which is what are
these three the third I think is that
when the world is so uncertain is very
hard for us to forecast what's going to
be the next product next season next
fashion
so instead of trying to improve your
forecasting maybe we should ensure that
we would just respond fast and flexible
responsive so agility is the first
property to replace the ability to
forecast well the second one is what I
called adaptability so when a world is
changing rapidly maybe there is no
perfect supply chain that you can speak
of yes it should we be manufacturing in
Mexico or should we even the factory in
China that might be the best solution
for today and very rapidly when you have
new technologies and when you have a new
product you may have to adapt to a new
way of running your process and the
third one is alignment meaning that we
have to make sure that we have to
identify both perhaps performance
measures reward structures risk sharing
kind of schemes to ensure that our
partners and we would be synchronized to
go north together to go west together so
that we would not be going in opposite
direction so those are the three that I
think are important so let me elaborate
a little more on these three and the
rest of the talk is more about exactly
what these we are about and why in fact
hopefully you'll see why these three
properties are important first one
agility so agility is important because
as I said that there is no way you can
exactly forecast the world in perfection
given the fact that you have so many
products and the world is changing so
rapidly so the way the best way is to
create a responsive engine now here I
think is very very nice framework that I
think is useful is the so-called Six
Sigma process so Six Sigma process which
was using quality control or which is
used in general management is actually
quite applicable in defining a
responsive and agile supply chain Six
Sigma process says that usually this is
the industry world of looking at what
Six Sigma process is about is to measure
to first measure measure to see what's
happening in your enterprise or your
quality process so you measure second is
that from measurement you derive what's
wrong potentially or whether things are
going in the right direction so you
learn about the process so once you
learn about the process you identify
what could be something that you need to
do to fix and when you respond you
better respond both respond with the
right
so you analyzed though which is the
right action and you must respond fast
because if you are responding to slow
that opportunity would be over and once
you finish action you measure again to
see whether that action does it or
whether you now enter into a different
kind of stage and therefore when the
next time when you go and measure you
are comparing the so-called status quo
which is different from before so this
Sigma process I think is a good concept
for us to see you say if we want to be
an earth child supply chain we must
measure we must measure to learn about
the changes fast rapidly so iBM has
called this kind of process this is an
IBM consulting type of console
terminologies they call these sense and
response which is the way to do a
trilogy is to sense where JA means you
must know before everyone else does
whether there has been some changes in
pattern changes in demand changes in
supply conditions
fast fast dancing and also fast response
so sense and response was the key
however I think IBM of course here this
is the IBM term and I always would not
just use other people especially
consultants concepts directly we process
and come up with better things so and
you'll see that this is better hopefully
you agree with me is that sense is not
enough because most of the times when
people talk about their chance of
matching sensing is important since it
means sensing finding out what's going
on how do we get sensors wow we have to
trap information with the find out
what's going on in the market with find
out what's going on in the supplier
supplier suppliers customers customers
and you use all kinds of technologies
internet a business or a barcode RFID
radio frequency identification so you
use as many technologies as you can to
try to find out what's going on sensing
is important but only if you can make
sense out of sense
I'm sure agree yeah only after sensing
all these information you'll be
overloaded you will be overwhelmed
because the best information is useless
unless you really understand what's
behind it so that's why I think
hence in response is insufficient here
is I think what is most powerful is that
you need to make sense out of sense it's
not because I'm just redundant I think
yeah you agree with me this is powerful
stuff
sense out of why do we need to make
sense out of sense because in general
when you sense what's going on in the
market there are lots and lots of noises
and there are lots and lots of bad data
informations that you thought you are
sensing about what's going on the market
demand customers preferences or could be
polluted there's a lot of distortion
going on wave going on those of you who
have taken the core operations remember
this perm everyone coming out of this
graduate school business must know where
prep I yes
don't know what will be the degree so
Boop is important what is move a poet is
a distortion of the market so when
people observe a signal they we process
it and they oftentimes exaggerate or
somehow distorted signal so that when
the signal is passed on to another stage
is dishwater
so how can you just lightly sense if you
sense without hands you would be mislead
and there would be a lot of death
signals you need to know who is your
customer really your customers may be
that customers if you know truly your
customers you would use different sense
out of it she's very different sense
yeah I remember that a few US years ago
I was invited to be a keynote speaker in
conference so I was very excited to give
a keynote but later on I discover that
before my speech organizer has organized
another another spy changers so I find
out I find out that it was magic Johnson
Magic Johnson was the other field
speaker so I said she what does Magic
Johnson know about safai chain how could
it be ahead of me
I thought maybe they want to warm up the
podium have magic tones that warm up the
podium warm up the audience so that they
would be ready to receive a real message
coming for me of course yeah
fascinating thing he said I think I
learned something from magic wands I
really learned something about me but he
gave a lecture a short lecture about 15
minutes long kind of a speech that I
really have learned something from him
so what magic transition is that
everyone I know surprising expert and I
don't know why they invited me to speak
yeah but anyway I have a simple message
to you the simple message is that you
thought you knew your customers you may
not that's it very simple knowledge a
lot of people thought they knew their
customers and when they read SEC knows
interpret and sense you may not know
your customers and so we share with the
experience you said after I retired from
basketball and I have money to invest I
invested in one of the investments that
I made is in cinema I invested in
cinemas buildings and cinemas these
cinemas I'd like to invest in immersed
in in the city in the city because
oftentimes the city people were deprived
of having a cinema they oftentimes have
to travel to downtown which expensive
places upwards to watch movie so we
wanted to invest in inner city to have
silver so that the inner city people can
have access but of course he didn't know
anything about universe so he purchased
a property
Oh Oh silver and old pages and try to
remodel it into a cinema and because he
has no knowledge about cinemas so he
hired an expert this expert this manager
has 35 years of experience of running
chambers take care of this
yeah so that person called the short and
do all the remodelings and take care of
things so the night before opening night
Magic Johnson went to the cinema and
Jack get things out and he walk around
how everything seems to be in great
order and so he's excited about this new
opening of his first cinema and then he
stopped at the food store as you know
your food is very important in cinema
that's how they make money
it's Telugu popcorns and disorders yes
at the ice creams candy bars and he
checked wooly stuff yeah fully stocked
with candy bars etc and then he
discovered that there will be 50 hot
dogs and then he doesn't ask this
managers people and this manager says
that mr. Johnson trust me I have 35
years of experience much more than you
of course you have zero yeah so people
come to a cinema
have popcorns at candy bars and so does
guess what the next day even before the
movie began they ran out they ran out of
stock
our dogs and so many close respondents
that the managers but in fact the
closing Twitter the bulk of the
customers who came to watch the movie in
history theater where people who of
course could not afford to have a nice
dinner after a movie or before the movie
if you are in a nice downtown area
subvert kind of cinemas people watch a
movie and then they go out to eat or die
snack a bar so of course while they're
in the cinema they don't eat meal they
they would have just a popcorn soda
because they are going to have a meal or
either before or after but a lot of the
customers of Magic Johnson's cinema were
people who knew movie so for them that
entertainment is the movie and the meal
must be together what they can afford is
a very nice way to have a meal when you
spend money already on the ticket of the
movie and so that's a very simple as a
powerful lesson you thought you knew the
customers may not and that's why you
need to make sense out of sense so here
is what I think is a powerful revision
of IBM stands in response it's sensible
sense and responsive response I like it
I'm gonna train my peers so that anybody
who use it now have to pay me yeah
so what is sensible sense sense common
sense when you sense you sends
information about what the market was a
supplier with the condition but I must
say just mentioning to you is that you
could set up a lot of antenna so the
preparedness means that you set up a lot
of antenna to find out what's going on
gap market conditions we know supplier
is a day late we know but you must make
knowledge out of that information so
that's the sensible sense maybe some of
them annoys you throw away don't use it
sensible sense so this is the activation
part which is once the data comes in
you have to create intelligence in
second portion is that response when you
talk about response companies also
invest a lot in extra capacity supplier
relationship but again until the action
happens so that you can indeed respond
fast
you response is no use yeah unless you
can have fast response there is always I
remember there was a common joke in
Silicon Valley in 1999 there was a
comment Europe let people say well I do
people have to spend so much efforts and
money to deal with y2k so what we need
to do is to have a very fast information
system so that as soon as New Zealand
hit y2k you have information immediately
knowing we have think is the country
intact what is the problem
yeah what kind of things we do that is a
very interesting of the user joke it's
it's a it's a is it's a good strategy if
your response is so fast if you can have
in 8 hours you can change your
information systems then of course then
don't invest in anything now just wait
until you watch yeah if New Zealand
doesn't mean yeah still the country is
intact and you don't need to do anything
so sense and response your response is
only good if you are responsive there as
if you are fast so I think the colour
portion is the one that most companies
miss which is what I meant is that you
need sensible sense and you need
responsive response so that's about it
yeah so those of you who have taken the
course in the information that ecology
course remember the company Zara this
company is an amazing company and
because I think they are truly an agile
company with sensible stands and
responsive response so they are able to
catch information fast from the market
and they're able to utilize information
to begin into knowing what the fashion
trends are and then manufacturer fast
manufacture and distribute fast
distribution is fast distribution is
amazingly fast within Zara everyday they
are distributing every
out of two distribution centers and
because speed is important which is why
this company has a nickname or a Wall
Street Journal for him fashion coherent
fashion on demand that he could create
fashion quick short time
another example is again for those of
you who have taken that cause remember
the 7-eleven Japan 7-eleven Japan is a
fascinating company which also have
sensible sense and responsive response
how do they do sensible sense I'll give
you two examples and you would be
impressed by this company 7-eleven Japan
what they did is that a lot of company
says that while sense sense is easy for
a retailer you just get poor no sales
take that quickly you get part of sales
like that quickly and send it back to
the headquarter so that we know today is
heaven up by selling tomorrow maybe
Google Cola is selling and then you
replenish fast
that's the Walmart kind of a strategy is
to get point of sales data fast
all systems hand them back to the
distribution center and the
distributions and the replenish is fast
so that would be good enough yes but
7-eleven Japan decided that that it's
just cents we need to have sensible
sense sensible channels would be what
one example that that that really is
truly a very powerful one and a few of
you may still remember but it's a year
ago so maybe not to many of you remember
so you still be enjoying this excellent
example now so what happened is that
about seven years ago 7-eleven started
to sound very well ladies pockets your
pendejo was selling like crazy
they're very good selling said plenty
hopes any 7-eleven Japan which of course
the convenience store not a department
store they would a number one in the
country so one of the vice-president of
7-eleven Japan proposed to CEO for both
the CEO say hey look mr. Suzuki yeah
suzuki-san did you know that we I think
there's opportunity this is sense and
let's respond by sensing here so the
response is that let's create a
but before we move I'm sure he would go
what a great question mr. Souki
brilliance Wow
yeah how come I didn't think of it so
let me go and do it so so this
vice-president ran off and research and
what he found as you know in 7-eleven
Japan they actually when they check out
at the checkout counter not only do they
just check scan your item so as to trap
your point of sales data but they also
are required this is a very very unique
retail chain in the world every checkout
counter person at hello
although each person here has to
estimate the age of the customer and
then input it so they are required
because they know it's so important to
know what a stores not only are we
interested in sales we are interested in
who was behind that sale so let s be
your the ask made by classified in the
group sure they have a special special
kind of machine checkout machine that
says twenty to thirty thirty to forty
forty fifty so that they ask me twenty
five years old and so you have to put
and the second thing is that you
secondly you have to estimate
the gender of the customer yes okay
probably not too hard yeah
so you can ask of course you cannot say
can you tell me your gender and age
before you buy the sushi yeah no so you
estimate so they were having this later
so when mr. Suzuki asked that question
is actually very easy they went back to
the surprise the back of the sales of
the pantyhose happened between 7 to 9
p.m.
okay good so so in fact there was a
reason of course because a lot of them
except Japan we still have a lot of male
working and female staying home kind of
this is the social norm it's always very
very convenient for the wife asked
husbands do they go out on the way back
home most of them also commute to work
that's a majority
yeah not driving is not as kind of
company yeah so every subway station
train stations there is a 7-eleven store
so on the way home
money yeah why don't you pick up what
half a dozen of these many hoes black
concise 38 with its number
I know a customer you can tell yeah so
so they would shop for their wife and
the Japanese were late hours nine
o'clock and they are exhausted but their
wife asked them to pick up any oh so
they have to stop by and pick up in the
ocean so once they find out this is
putting intelligence in the sense mr.
Suzuki asked the vice president should
we still expand the cosmetics ception no
no need now let's move all the pantyhose
next to the beer section see sensible
sense would create smart response yes if
you are not fast if you are not fast and
you are not responsive you will fall
into the victim of what happened to
Erikson in 2000 when they would say fire
in the cookie the fire not destroy but
it's just a small fire in a clean room
of the Philips semiconductor Factory of
course it's a very very clean room you
know even if it's not a big fire but
once the fireman came in with the hose
and water yeah you are disabled for a
long time so Nokia was able to identify
the informations and the CEO next day
III sent a SWAT of vice-president out
because they have been burned before
yeah so they know that it's important
for them there to react by knowing what
is going on so you need sense and then
immediately develop a strategy to take
advantage of the extra capacity of
Philips in Singapore and I drove and
change the design of the product so that
I can make use of other processes and in
the end they did not suffer any
shortages but Ericsson did not do sense
nor good response because they didn't
sense the way it work you said the Eretz
and people also learn about the fire and
so they asked Philip yeah what happened
do you have a severe fire and the very
people of course has an interest to kind
of try to be emphasized the seriousness
of the problem and so there was a fire
but it was
less than half an hour so it's no big
deal
please go back to sleep don't worry here
and they got a time when they learn
about the seriousness so Erikson
suffered 500 million US dollars lost
open 5 billion from nurse because of one
fire so that's important second
adaptability adaptability I use an
example that some of you in the global
operations was remember it's looser in
the 80s and the 90s loosen use a
strategy of a supply chain of
concentrated manufacturing concentrated
manufacturing means that they would
concentrate manufacture in a single
location in that case in Oklahoma City
why because they said most of our
customers are the US and most of our
suppliers are in the US so let's take
advantage of economies of scale which
pulling centralized procurement
centralized feeding centralized
manufacturing that's the way to take
control of the technologies in the 90s
they discovered that that would not work
they would not work because most of a
surprise that Muto Asia and the
fastest-growing market is in Asia in
China so what they found is that too
much food the vice president's of
manufacturing once told me is that they
have a supply chain strategy that's
because they would fly all these
components from Asia to Oklahoma City
store them and then eventually put them
together final example keep them catch
them and then fly them back to Asia it
cost at a time and the worst thing is
that they all did not earn any frequent
flier miles so it was a nuisance Lucia
so anyway so they they change they
change the supply chain in 1996 they
move manufacturing to Taiwan they move
furniture to Taiwan because then the
Asian hub can serve the Asian market and
can do the Pope humans there's no need
for them to fly things around it was a
very successful strategies but then I
think adaptation is never if there's no
end to an education at that because the
world is changing all the time so when
the technology is in early days and the
content Sheila supply demand the loser
strategies of focused manufacturing
focused Oklahoma City worked like a
charm
on as the man becomes more widespread
and suppliers are also widespread they
have this regional expanded network
strategy that also is fine but when the
technology is fully mature what happened
is that a lot of the outsource
manufacturers can do the job equally
well structure so what news I don't have
to do is to change the value chain by
outsourcing you don't need to do it all
yourself which is what loosened it
what loosened it is that they
drastically started outsourcing recently
because they recognize that holding on
to manufacturing is the wrong strategy
when the technology is really mature so
you need to adapt another example of
adaptation is a company called Pascal
which is a very successful steel
manufacturer they are not number one in
the world in terms of size but their
profits is larger than number two when
number one two three four and together
so the largest that they are number four
in size but if you add the top the top
five except for school at the total
profits cost who has largely profit than
the rest of it so this company is
successful well there's some very
interesting lessons that I think we can
learn from Pasco in the early days Pasco
used a centralized purchase so called
continuous casting technology why
because that save energy and also is a
very very good process to enable you to
do the steel manufacture steel casting
and the muse has been concentrated in
Korea because the bulk of the demand of
course in the early days Korea was going
through rapid reconstruction after the
Second World War and so the demand from
career but what happened is that today
the world has changed
the world has changed because the
ingredients the inputs to make-- steel
is not in Korea in Brazil in Australia
and that horse has been going up so
controlling the source is important
second is that transportation cost has
also skyrocketed and China is hungry for
steroids we all know in China even
though the supply of steel has increased
but the demand of Steel has even much
higher so compete with China is very
hard so what POSCO did i do is that the
old concentrated supply chains where he
has worked
for them but not anymore when you have
to compete for inputs and when
transportation cost is much higher than
before so what they did is this
integration so they this integrated
their supply chain by having now
factories forming joint ventures with
the key suppliers I know in Brazil in
Australia where the iron ores are so
they build I'll make them in the crude
steel and then do the finishing in the
market market being the US and China of
course there's some in Korea but because
the big markets rapidly increasing
markets in the u.s. in China
why do I have to bring all these iron
ore in core go into career and build
them and then you have to ship them to
China and US very expensive remember
transportation cost so adaptation is
another very important strategies and
POSCO is a successful company because
they never just live with a single
solution they attempt finally finally is
very important alignment this importance
is because as we depend on our partners
to make products and services it's not
sufficient for you to say I am a really
excellent company and I do the best
operations because the weakest link of
our supply chain defines as a parching
if you have a supply chain and some of
the partners are not working well you
would be vulnerable
so the weakest link yeah we're talking
about supply chain to supply some
competitions and we must make sure with
meaning everyone wins not just one wins
yes so so importance to have win winter
absolutely important so one example is
Prius Prius of course is a very
successful hybrid that we all know but
when Toyota introduced the Prius first
initially seven years ago eight years
ago Prius was not kind of a sure winner
at that time Toyota introduced a product
talking to the dealers hey mister
dealers yeah we want you to sell Prius
will the policy out we don't know okay
who knows the Americans who take care
about this fuel-efficient car well it's
very risky and plus
the worst thing is that a lot of the
pots were not coming with Kamri or with
the growler
so there is a separate set of spare
parts just a battery charger it's very
expensive so what you notice is that the
retailers I want dealers I want you to
sell fish you don't know what the
product will sell or not but of course
once I ship you the Prius according to
the to notice agreement like other cars
as soon as I ship you own it you pay me
if it doesn't say that's your problem
yeah I first and plus you have to invest
in the spare parts you invest in the
Chargers and a lot of new equipment so
what happens is that this is an equal
and equal risk the risk is of course
much higher for the small little dealers
compared to a giant companies like
Toyota who can absorb the risk much
better so the unequal risk means that
who knows that could have their way
because they have powerful company and
they can save you I this is it yeah you
have to do it otherwise I won't give you
our of the dealership network but they
recognize that the dealers would be
doing it so they're the incentive would
not be aligned if they create this an
equal risk sharing so to the credit of
the motor they modify this they modify
saying that for this product only if you
sell peers we take the risk of the
product for other cars that's not the
case for other cars Camry as soon as we
should be coming to you you own the
product and you cannot sell it you
markdown you do whatever you want that's
your problem
you pay me first but for Prius I take
ownership of the products I have the
product capped at the distribution
center and near the dock near the port
when you have successfully so peers I've
said it to you otherwise you only sell
you're an agent and that is the balance
of the risk and it worked
as a result the incentives were aligned
and the dealers are much more willing to
work hard to get this products because
they also know there's always much
better margin because I don't need to
have to borrow money to finance the
inventory for this car
this car I have much better imagine
telling so the dealers are incentivized
to work hard and then there was a side
bonus it turns out the Saipan wish was
that if Toyota has been using the old
regime old methods of sending asking the
dealers to take ownership what do you
think would be the estimate that they
would use in terms of whether we should
send more cars to the northeast to the
northwest and the west coast they would
use no better estimate except just use
camping or Corolla that's what we are
selling so if if the west coast people
know California there's five to six
percent of the total US market of Camry
is in North Korea California we send
five to six percent peers to them if the
South years which is the big the oil
state taxes Florida has twenty percent
we sent three percent there but because
this time they're not sending things out
there centralizing they would luck out
because it turns out Prius demand is
very different from the rest of the u.s.
for the rest of the car turns out that
in the previous case North California
takes 25 percent of the Prius market so
we know Californians the country and
some he's only got six six percent so in
this case 202 lucked out because if they
have spent how to do the wrong place you
can imagine that it is south years they
have to do a lot of math times and then
the north in indicate Northern
California they have to fight to get
peers so this is important with another
example of alignment is so poor supplier
huh yeah what is the supply hub the
supplier happens usually today companies
like there come used to be compared and
HP all of them Cisco or recognized they
don't like inventory nobody likes
inventory so they set up a super hub
which is a warehouse next to them very
close to them and as the suppliers to
send him Android there but they don't
own the Cisco would not only mentor it
yeah would not only mentor that
inventory still yours every morning when
I go and pick up then becomes mine but
so when you ship even if you are a from
the Asia Singapore yeah you ship all the
products stores
you take ownership until I take it so
that's very very much like a vending
machine you have any machine this
manufacturers to make the products send
the product all the way to the vending
machine is to own the product until you
pick and get it so let's go down or like
this very much yeah because of course
then they don't have to buy the
inventory into the factory which they
you have to take ownership and subject
to the risk so they asked the supply to
bear the risk but this is not fair you
know
cause some suppliers of course if you
are Intel you know this is not that bad
a deal to take ownership and India
usually doesn't take ownership anyway
they're strong enough to say no I don't
play this game but if you're a smaller
suppliers you have to play according to
the rule and yet at the same time you
have to borrow money to finance
inventory a small supplier has to borrow
money and a heavy heavy interest rate
because you're as small sometimes
start-up companies and you're the
financial only mentor it's very
expensive so in a way it's not fair
because the weakest player in the supply
chain is shouldering a much bigger
liability than cost yes
so some statistical I got from a company
called world chain that says that in the
2000s you know a lot of companies are
actually shifting the inventory burden
to the suppliers is very component
manufacturer supplier semiconductor they
were shouldering a lot more inventory
than before and these are smaller guys
than there and yet they are they're
borrow money heavily so so this is not a
good way to run the supply chain so a
new way is the following a new way is
there some financial intermediaries used
to be Silicon Valley Bank started
sinking they then created this solution
what secretary bank says is that will
buy the inventory from this mortgage
will buy it because we are Silicon
Valley Bank we can finance the inventory
at much better rate we are back so we
can borrow money at a much lower
interest rate than anybody else in the
supply chain and then we just purchased
finance take the inventory and when down
is it we sell them together so in a way
everybody is better off because the
interest rate the difference of the
interest rate is sufficient for you to
pay Silicon Valley Bank
and steal you're better off so today GE
Capital is doing it UPS capital other
companies rushing in to do this
financial reengineering
they should try to correct some of the
imbalance of the liabilities so I think
to some sum up and then I want to open
up for some questions is that I think 3a
the first a is important and the trick
to do first a well agility well is to do
sensible sense and responsive response
yeah so don't just sense it response
make some sense out of sense and
response second one adaptive adaptive
means that we must recognize there is a
market condition change there is the
technology change for lifecycle change
and you may have to change your solution
in response to those change and the
third one is alignment alignment means
that we look at the supply chain
partners maybe we have to change who is
responsible for what maybe we have to
change the way we share risk we share
cost and we share reward maybe we also
have to expand the notion of performance
measures what is the performance
measures once we are partnered and
integrated we cannot simply say this is
my territory I measure only my within my
territory and that's yours maybe we have
to have some joint ownership of some
performance measures because we
integrated the course we want to make
sure we align interest so that's
alignment so three things are very
simple first agility sensible sends the
response adaptive adaptive based on
market conditions or product life cycles
technology cycles alignment which is the
exchange of responsibility decision
right sharing risk and cost and rewards
and three defining performance measures
so to me those are the three properties
and hopefully come and more companies
will recognize these three days to
become triple a performance as well
thank you very much thank you
quistis yes sorry you've spoken to a lot
of these different companies I'm
thinking back to the original chart that
you'd shown the difference being a
leader and a laggard what about those
companies in your opinion having perhaps
spent time with both of them what's the
difference between the two of them in
terms of their management I think number
one is that companies need to recognize
that surprising matters looking at
supply chain looking at human process
and not just think that this is a
necessary evil yeah number one so number
two is that usually what I found though
successful companies are where the
c-level people are the one
spending time understanding this
understanding the operations to try to
create a copy wide awareness yes and the
third one is that there's not a fixed
target it's not like yes we arrived here
and so very happy let's all celebrate so
it's very much a continuous it kind the
Kaizen kind of further mentality is to
continuous improvement in the necessary
so I think in a way you can say that a
lot of these are culture because the
corporate culture the company having the
culture of looking into the supply chain
issues and not delegated to save a VC
level only worry about investments let
somebody else manage this actual
delivery and make making of the products
here so I think it's in a simple simple
way you say is there is a culture it's
approaching culture operations cause we
have some discussions of companies such
as Amazon and eBay type of companies
yeah well the way you organize your
software it could be the way you
organize your software may be in the
modular structure so that you can easily
be flexibly customize the products where
you enter into the China market or India
market so you'll be able to quickly
customize the products which would
enable you to fit the needs of the local
markets and also have fast delivery so I
think software has similar even though
it's not tangible physical products but
you do need to have this type of speed
you do need to have this flexibility and
responsibility and even in the software
case you cannot be just by yourself you
have partners you need partners and so
you also have to align the interests of
the partners in the case of Amazon of
course you
Postal Service UPS type of companies
that they have worried about the actual
delivery and Amazon when they went to
Japan they had to partner with the
convenience store a very successful
venture today Amazon just broke 1
billion dollar mark in Japan and the
success of Japan is not just purely
e-commerce sales for Amazon is a very
successful partnership with the
convenience store so that customers
would go to the web to order products
and pick up products after you have
order from Amazon and pay also at the
convenience store so there's a very
interesting partnership model now you
have to make sure that the convenience
to are rewarded adequately in order for
them to be willing to be your last smile
but again it means that software
companies cannot live on only themselves
you may have current course
in the strategy course we talked about
into it which also require partnerships
with other companies to provide an
extended service of the financial
services mortgage not every such deal
they have done well have been producing
results but again we cannot live in a
kind of a single enterprise mode
software very much software service
they're very similar principle except it
may not be as physically tangible yeah
very good thank you yeah